مع نهايه كل عام البحث عن توقعات الابراج
وعلم الفلك للعام الجديد تاتي اولا يترقب
الكثيرون تنبؤات ابراجهم وحدودهم لسنه
الجديده
وما هي الابراج الاكثر حظا لهذا العام
[موسيقى]
برج الحمل كم عنده مشاكل
عاطفيه سابقه ان شاء الله راح تنحل هذه
السنه الجديده بس عم بشدهمته بالعمل
والعمل يكون كثير صاير بالنسبه له برج
الحمل
الثور
برج الثور
بالنسبه له من سنه الماضيه
جديده بس اكثر شيء بيركز على السفر
[موسيقى]
تمام الاسد عنده ثلاث اموال يعني الاسد
عنده اموال كثير قويه عنده
فينا نقول انه نص السنه راح يكون كلها
عندها
راح يكون كثير
[موسيقى]
اموال وخسر كثير اشياء
التزام الميزان لازم يركز هالسنه صراحه
انه هو تركيزه مال مال هذه الفتره هذه
السنه تركيزه ومال وينتبه لصحته برج
الميزان عنده شويه جو صحي ما راح يعجبه
برج الميزان عيد الفتره او هذه السنه او
نصف السنه تحديدا
العقرب العقرب العقرب
بده يبتدي يغير عن نفسه لانه سنه اللي مضت
عن نفسه ابدا بده يغير عن نفسه وياخذ
قرارات قويه ممكن عمليه ممكن عاطف كثير
عنده مفاجاه حلوه برج العقرب
مقاس عنده ممكن اشتراكات عمليه برات البلد
عنده اوراق قانونيه راح تكون بصالحه باذن
الله راح يكون اموره هيك متداوله طول
السنه
[موسيقى]
يسعدني صباح الجنه
طيب الدلو الدلو الدلو
لازم نتعلم من اخلاقه لانه عن جد هو غلط
كتير سنت الماضي بده يصلح حاله وجايته
اموال كثير حلوه برج الدلو يدير باله على
مصروفه يركز على حاله وعنده امور قانونيه
برات البلد راح تكون ان شاء الله
برج الحوت الحوت
عندنا الحوت
يعني عاطفيا بكل شيء تعب الحوت بس الحوت
عنده من هذه السنه سنه سنه
بس راح يعوضه ان شاء الله عنده تعويض كثير
قوي نور طب اذا نقدر نحكي اكثر الابراج
الاسد
[موسيقى]